take a seat sit down through the wall
hello and welcome to PlayStation create
ok something something happened
I played the outer worlds and it's
fantastic and I thought we should play
some of it together but the thing is I
can play this game correctly or I can
play this game like a complete space
[ __ ] and we're going with the latter
choice today so we're going to create a
character and murder everyone we are
doing no missions we are taking everyone
out just to show you how different this
game could be so let's do this I think
she's done I've asked Twitter to name
her we've had some weird names Agnes but
I'm gonna go with Maddie because she's a
mad one muddy grenade let's go yeah I
don't even started we're already this
game is going well let's do more of this
so I need to move those oh hello hey you
you've tried the best now now try the
rest
spacely's choice oh wow that stinks
shall we patch him up or just swear oh I
didn't mean to press that like you're
bleeding we did something nice so I
didn't mean to patch him up all right
I'm sorry about that
see those canisters by the entrance
Marauders come sniffing around in here
and I can take them all out with a
single shot
not bad huh you can take you can take
someone out with a single shot
yeah I don't believe that mate no but we
got intimidate you're an idiot
give me your gun before you get yourself
killed a lot like my lieutenant here
hope this gun serves you better than it
did me here you can have my saber too
for patching me up and all all space
versus weapons are now 30 percent less
likely to malfunction
you just give me a good one I think I'm
going to do yes spaces choice I need you
to test out this gun so let's not do
this anymore me cuz I'm off right space
part 1 let's go what's next is this the
show that I is a nice ship say that's a
nice you just tell me what to do do you
not know that I'm Spaceballs
down what are you gonna make you get can
you kill me can you get me shoot whoa
whoa okay the music is epic but the man
exploded then did you see that you've
been promoted promoted here we go
let's slice and dice you just yeah yeah
you just have a lay down and relax oh oh
in a knife fight see it played a knife a
spoon with reason or knife that's not a
knife where did you go
what did you what killed you oh you
don't need that anymore
slumach what I grind shots yeah
oh it took a flake oh sorry about that
Dave I hope we can still be friends okay
I've got a ship I get it I get it we can
cut all that out let's go back into the
wilderness who are you Human Resources
town sent me here about to check on the
guard check on the gods yeah how's that
going for you mate I don't mind telling
you I told so I could say I killed them
I could lie the gods accidentally
brutally shot themselves whilst on
patrol or just be about us which we are
I don't like your tone oh you're just
out here doing my trade gathering
remains tang and corpses found reports
yes I'd better get to clean it up can't
just leave company property scattered
about bleeding out on that's a good
point so don't you actually give a crap
that they died oh I like thanks very
much I will be on my way now
and one last thing Ernest you can be the
first victim of the Tommyknocker
activities trespassing lock-picking
what's that one hacking and murdering
are all illegal what about smashing a
guy in the head that all his limbs
explode I'm very sorry about that
Ernest so we found a new town this is
Edgewater
slow motion oh you took it like a jets
in the groin are the glide shot takes it
duck
he's just flailing now oh we have a real
fight oh that didn't last long for you
did it dude okay this is now my town
where did your head go doesn't matter
doesn't matter at all thanks for your
time
let's go into town so this is Edgewater
barber shop random moon picture what are
you two chatting about the walls he
heard something outside the walls
outside there anything now can you world
resident resident he's evil the other
guy go where did you go oh I see you
don't run dude don't run don't run shoot
Tommyknocker all the way now Tommy knock
about life nope nope please stop hitting
me sleep this will be this tournament is
our last stunt anyone comes in there get
Tommy not good there we go and you scope
nicely done
next victim please look at the on the
floor well good going to hell come on
inside
take a seat sit down bad stuff before
sleep damn
Dominic oh this just feels so good that
music when he kicks in is so epic have
some lady bag or lift one thing I know
about less when we get him one it
usually means bossfight check out the
music that is how you take out a boss
new location another town or technical
gardens okay there's a group do you
thinking what I'm thinking
shall we do this let me just cut save
damn it
here we go who do you think the leader
is the person with the gun okay grace oh
my word is more than I thought
I'll swing it
a uniform can't dammit man what eunuchs
what that what the hell are you just
eating or something look at the size of
that hey guys hey guys
she'll do a mature joke check out the
size of the snake between my legs
yep this is what you come for yeah sorry
Oh new enemy type one of those fly-in
feckers I got three in one swipe there
look just legit I'm just the greatest
playoff legit legit what have you got
Patera dactyls what the hell are they
and they like gorillas or some ah we can
have to fight them yes I'm shaving
don't judge me I'm trying to use a
Tommyknocker against a gorilla
I'm going to save okay now we battle
stealthy stealthy stealthy stealthy
stealth come on no face any wet there
held it what the hell did it do is that
the same one holy [ __ ] whoa you are
fast onion I can get rid of the little
one there we go sorry about the kid
can we win this fight let's take an West
does that mean oh I just got
bitch-slapped whoa phone
are nothing near don't don't love this
all right across the jaw he's not happy
with that 100 look at my health oh my
word look away there we go
Mama's down we're gonna knock you out
marvelous do not doubt come on come at
me bro don't pick it up don't forget up
try to warn you
so flora and fauna are quite nice round
here what the hell if they like made of
rocks or something I'm a stealth master
they'll never find me on top of the
shelving unit inside here they'll never
spot me she's coming around
just coming around she's [ __ ] me
straight away ow damn it right let's do
this in slow motion set themselves on
fire
ah dude is he a spy that mates I will
help put it out put out the fire
there you go there you go you're okay
now you're okay
what the hell is that
no this is going to be fun what the hell
is that you're gonna shrink you biggie
[Music]
Danny bacon sandwich toxic does he talk
to the pig I'll talk to the pig sorry
the tumors are still edible that is
disgusting
come on we do something real there we go
pull the power power relay it did it I'm
an engineer best in the world did it
down Oh just broke my leg
yeah so new station like a space station
this one hello young lady I have a
shrink ray Oh big girl big girls you are
beautiful
every time I knock her in your face Oh
oh definitely not going to survive this
we we we've we're dead you live and
learn
you live you learn you die Hawthorne you
said let me apologize in advance I'm
about to ruin your day
according to your ship's record you've
been flagged by the board your ship will
be impounded until such a time as they
see fit to lift it you're taking my ship
from me captain naught Z naught we
should know I will have my vengeance
this life or the next
in fact I'm coming to get my revenge
right now you and me my electric knit
comb axe gonna get intimate should we
use this so should we go for the
Tommyknocker
yeah Tommy not for this guy's freaking
brain in my ship he's not even hurt in
the slightest this is not going well I'm
sorry I'm sorry I can dodge every bullet
come on let's try and kill one of them
at least you'll do
please so you run this station do you
sir can you shut up please
I want to talk to this guy you've
already figured out what I'm doing
haven't you that was possibly the string
creek Quebec Street grain your grind too
funny killed him sorry sorry
we died together if that's anything to
go by don't let go Jack um should we
talk about this there's a guy with a
moon on his head hey Martin can I have
your helmet
as a nice polish Tomica wall okay mr.
Parker hardcore right this is the moment
of truth can we wear that ridiculous
helmet myth-busting in every game we
play now these days all right I'm gonna
cut that out because I just bought for
all my money a laser sword was more like
a laser dagger but it looks like a sword
we're gonna kill everyone on this space
station because that's what we do
anymore always run left is that the hole
I think that's everyone now uh one more
coming with your lightsaber come on
geezer you are the last remaining man
alive or woman let's not judge doesn't
matter what genitalia you've got let's
do this bro he changed his mind
bad times what do you think I'm doing
damn what a warrant whatever I want I'm
sorry
don't question me I'm space right now
we've got this or we can go back to find
captain wheeler surprise monkey truck up
captain wheeler
you cannot take my ship ever again mr.
stark I don't feel so good okay so
awesome this new planet
it looks um doesn't like this human life
what well we figured it out there is
dragons
aliens lizards who are very strong oh my
word I regret this fight already
I just want to kill one of them I know
I'm underpowered just one of them I know
what to do if we am a shrink-ray they
might make it a little easier that one
we're gonna kill that one that little
tiny shrink ray
let's go bro
I don't know I don't know to think we
can get through this shall we fight to
the death is it worth it let's do this
you only live twice I'm gonna hit it you
wait watching it I'm gonna hit this last
[Music]
you know what what floss tutorial what
do you mean I now have a flaw
I'm acrophobic now because I've been
jumping around like an idiot for too
long after repeatedly falling from great
heights you no longer function well when
the ground is not beneath you oh thanks
so trying to do shots whilst jumping
through the air was a bad idea but thank
you that's pretty cool system is it so
it gives you an extra skill point but
the bad thing is that you operate worse
in those scenarios in future I like that
anyway that was the outer worlds if you
want me to play some more I'm happy to
do so shall we try and finish the entire
game by murdering everyone we see and
everything we see thank you for watching
I really do appreciate it if you got to
this point can you write like a boss
like a mouse in the comments I will try
and find you and give you some love
because nobody stays this long maybe you
do I'll shut up now I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade this is the
brilliant the outer worlds let me know
your thoughts see ya
hey Doc hey Doc hey Doc why don't you
start taking this stuff seriously